[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
lactu qui fait le tour comme chaque jour
de votre information locale et on débute
cette édition avec l'image du jour et la
présentation ce matin au Technocentre de
cuit en cours de la nouvelle Renault
Twingo 3e génération du nom principale
révolution de ce nouveau modèle un
moteur à l'arrière du véhicule la Twingo
devient aussi pour la première fois une
CIN porte pour le reste elle sera
déclinable en quatre couleurs
l'habitacle sera personnalisable et vous
pourrez connecter votre smartphone pour
en faire un tableau de bord chez Renault
on a souhaité un retour aux sources avec
la première génération de la petite
citadine comme nous l'explique Carsten
krap directeur du programme Twingo quand
on parle de Twingo on parle de la saga
Twingo donc la la Twingo elle a la
première la twingo 1 a été présentée en
1992 au Salon de Paris ça c'était la
twingo 1 ensuite on l' remplacé en 2007
par Twingo 2 et avec cette Twingo 3 on
voulait surtout retrouver un peu le
caractère innovant et iconique de Twingo
qu'elle était à ses débuts dans les dans
les années 90 donc cette Twingo elle est
c'est vraiment une voiture citadine avec
une architecture très particulière dès
2008 d'ailleurs nos ingénieurs se sont
vraiment penchés sur la question comment
rendre ou retrouver ce caractère
innovant et ça s'est traduit par cette
architecture très particulière en tout
cas sur ce segment là donc une
architecture avec moteur arrière et ce
cette architecture avec le moteur
arrière c'est vraiment au bénéfice du
client il y a vraiment deux raisons
majeurs ou deux bénéfices majeurs pour
le client avec cette architecture
arrière c'est la grande
habitabilité et la compacité extérieure
c'estàd je peux citer deux chiffres
cette voiture là elle est 10 cm plus
courte par rapport à Twingo 2
extérieurement et à l'intérieur de la
boîte à Gan jusqu'à l'arrière jusqu'au
seuil de coffre on va retrouver 22 cm de
plus on reste sur le thème de
l'automobile avec une nouvelle victoire
pour l'avocat Rémy jossum face à la
mairie de Montini le Bretonneux
spécialisé dans le code routier il vient
de faire annuler par le tribunal de
police de Versailles des PV de
stationnement des PV de station fnement
dont les tarifs ont été jugés
illégalement fixés par le maire c'est la
troisème fois en 6 ans qu'il gagne un
procès face à la municipalité Patrick
Jacques de dixmud et Jonathan vilm
Jonathan vilman pour les
images nouvelle victoire pour l'avocat
Rémy jossum face à la mairie de Montini
le Bretonneux le tribunal de police de
Versailles a rendu sa décision le 14
février les procès verbaux de
stationnement dressés par la police
municipale ne sont pas conformes à la
législation les tarifs pour ces PV
doivent être fixé par le conseil
municipal ou bien le maire seul s'il
obtient une délégation néanmoins cette
délégation doit respecter certaines
conditions cette délégation doit être
encadrée définie délimitée et là le
conseil municipal a donné tout pouvoir
sans limitation au maire de sorte que et
bien cette délégation du conseil
municipal vient en contradiction avec le
code général des collectivités
territoriales c'est la troème victoire
en 6 ans de l'avocat dans sa bataille
contre les PV illégaux dressé par la
municipalité de Montini en 2008 il avait
prouvé que le code de la route
n'obligeait en rien les automobilistes à
afficher leur tickets au rodateur en
2010 il a fait annuler des procès
verbaux car la mairie n'avait pas
expliqué clairement pourquoi elle
faisait payer leur stationnement aux
automobilistes ce sont donc des failles
dans les arrêtés municipaux qu'exploite
à chaque fois l'avocat pour gagner ses
procès et du côté de la mairie on donne
le sentiment d'être un peu résigné la
fixation des prix c'est pas c'est pas
limité alors qu'on doit le limiter bon
ça a toujours été fait comme ça je veux
dire bon je n'ai rien inventé hein c'est
c'est c'est mes services qui établissent
les choses donc voilà mais après je
pense qu'il va encore continuer à
gratter pour trouver encore quelque
chose vous savez les lois évoluent
tellement il faut en en permanence en
permanence il faut se remettre à jour
donc vous savez des changements
permanents dont devra en tout cas se
méfier la prochaine équipe
municipale mardi Marie soltouren
ministre de la Santé l'a annoncé les
sages-femmes après plus de 4 mois de
lutte vont obtenir un nouveau statut
médical à l'hôpital André Mignot de
Versailles cette avancée est plutôt
bienvenue même si on demande à voir
concrètement ce que ces annonces vont
donner Jonathan villman pour les
images un nouveau statut pour les
sages-femmes Marie soltouren ministre de
la Santé l'a annoncé hier matin les
sages-femmes qui entrent dans leur 5e
mois de grève ont été entendu et les
choses devraient bouger un nouveau
statut des compétences mieux reconnues
ou encore une rémunération revalorisé
sur le principe les nouvelles semblent
plutôt bonnes oui mais sur le principe
seulement pour les sages-femmes à qui on
promet beaucoup depuis longtemps sans
jamais rien de concret ensuite alors
forcément elle reste prudente face aux
annonces le mouvement cette année il
fait il dure depuis le mois d'octobre le
16 octobre précisément mais l'histoire
d'accéder à un statut spécifique pour
les sages-femmes date déjà une une
revendication qui date déjà depuis 2001
donc voilà on demande à voir déjà
certaines réponses du ministère ne
satisfont pas la profession pas de
statut similaire au médecins dentist ou
pharmacien comme réclamé et une
revalorisation salariale au stade de
projet dont les négociations n'ouvriront
qu'au mois d'avril autre point qui
divise la création d'un statut hors
fonction publique pour les sages-femmes
les syndicats craignent dans ce cas une
précarisation de la profession c'est une
crainte qu'ils ont mainten il y a des
lois qui disent qu'il faut X sagfemme
pour X nombre d'accouchement pourquoi si
on change de statut il y aurait besoin
de moins de sages-femmes on le comprend
pas d'ors et déjà les sages-femmes ont
annoncé que la grève était maintenue au
plan national le mouvement devrait même
se durcir dans les prochaines
semaines nous partons maintenant à la
rencontre d'un ivelinois qui a choisi de
s'expatrier en Amérique du Nord et plus
précisément au Québec Renand duet a
grandi dans le département depuis sa
naissance en
1987 sa passion le mono cycle qu'il
pratique en freestyle un talent qu'il
développe aujourd'hui dans une
prestigieuse école de cirque à
l'étranger un reportage de Nicolas
kirilovitz de Franck David pour Radio
sensation et TVfil
78 c'est ici à l'École nationale de
cirque de Montréal que Renand et son
partenaire d'Orient font ce qu'ils
aiment monocycle acrobatie porté au
sol le cirque c'est leur passion et ils
veulent la faire
[Musique]
partager on cherche plutôt à des fois à
provoquer un peu le public à lui faire
peur aller le
ouais le faire le faire trembler avec
nous qu des fois c'est l'idée c'est le
CIR c'est aussi du danger et c'est ça
qu'on va exploiter des fois et comment
on va faire réagir le public à ce
niveau-l je crois qu' nous on essaie
surtout de de pousser le public dans ses
retranchements dans les endroits où il a
jamais été Renant commence à jongler à
l'âge de 9 ans quelques années plus tard
il monte une association avec des amis
mais c'est en sortant de l'université
qu'il saute le pas et entre à l'École de
cirque de Lyon il y rencontre Dorian
aujourd'hui son partenaire qui le suivra
jusqu'à Montréal c'est mieux là en plus
d'être amis d'abord on est collègue de
travail et puis en plus d'être juste
collègue de travail on est porteur
voltiger donc il y a aussi une question
de confiance de sécurité de de mise en
genre je mets ma vie entre ses mains
entre guillemets donc il y a a aussi une
une confiance extrême entre guillemets
qui se place Renand est dans sa 2e année
ici à l'École nationale de cirque de
Montréal une école renommée dans le
monde entier et très formatrice pour les
jeunes artistes ils sont d'ailleurs 150
à suivre des cours ici ici justement
Renan peut se perfectionner accompagné
d'anciens artistes aujourd'hui devenu
professeur que là je monte je sais que
je sais qu'il va me falloir du temps
pour me placer puis je vois le mur
arriver oui mais il va très vite il
accélère parce que les épaules sont pas
là ouais
ok je suis d'accord mais tu es pasessus
donc il peut il peut pas tourner parce
que ça
accélère on veut des éléments techniques
le plus difficile possible parce que les
genses le spectaculaire d'un autre côté
s'il y a pas d'histoire qui accompagne
la technique ça devient du sport qui est
pas méchant soi mais c'est pas les es du
Circle et nous on enseigne les es du
circle
[Musique]
travail et rigueur sont nécessaires pour
que Renand devienne à son tour un
artiste de cirque mais le plus difficile
c'est la distance avec les proche on a
fait beaucoup de sacrifices en venant
ici par rapport à nos familles nos
amis on aura envie de de repasser à
nouveau du beaucoup de temps France je
pense mais c'est une chance d'avoir une
ouverture sur sur l'Amérique du Nord
comme ça euh
avoir des contacts avec la tou avec le
Festival MONTRÉAL COMPLÈTEMENT CiRQUE
c'est des choses qui sont hyper hyper
favorable pour l'avenir 95 % des élèves
qui sortent de l'école de cirque de
Montréal sont embauchés dans des
troupes mais le rêve de Renant c'est de
créer sa propre compagnie toujours avec
Dorian et sachez si le Québec vous
intéresse vous fait rêver que ce
dimanche 9 mars sur sensation Eveline
98.4 l'émission Un zeste d'info sera
entièrement consacrée à cette province
francophone du Canada des idées de
séjour mais aussi des rencontres avec
d'anciens ivelinois vous y seront
proposé meilleur apprenti de France un
titre dont rêve de nombreux jeunes et et
une réalité pour quatre ivelinois parmi
eux Anaël et Cameron tous deux ont
réussi ce prestigieux concours national
nous les avons suivi jusqu'au Sénat pour
leur remise de prix claire Cambier et
Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude c'est dans le somptueux décor de
la salle des conférences du Sénat que
les meilleurs apprentis de France ont
reçu leur récompense de la cuisine à la
mode en passant par la prothèse daire
tous les secteurs étaient représentés
parmi ces jeunes prodiges anaë et
Cameron portaient les couleurs du
département des ivelines leur spécialité
l'art de la table et du service quand on
voit tous les meilleurs ouvriers de
France tout enfin tous les cuisiniers
avec le col bleu blanc rouge qui
viennent vous serrer la main qui
viennent vous parler et cetera enfin
c'est déjà ça c'est c'est beau et puis
c'est vrai qu'on est sur un lieu quand
même assez magnifique quoi impressionnés
et ravis ils ont reçu leur diplôme et
bien entendu la fameuse médaille d'or du
concours de Meilleur apprentis de France
là juste
ici qu'est-ce que ça fait justement
d'avoir reçu ici dans c'est un pur
bonheur c'est ça énormément plaisir pour
obtenir cette médaille d'or ils ont dû
obtenir une note supérieure à 16/ 20 aux
sélections départementales régionale et
enfin à la finale nationale une poignée
seulement sont récompensé dans chaque
filière pour arriver à un tel niveau il
a fallu se préparer un an et demi
d'entraînement avec leur professeurs
c'est lui qui a repéré leur potentiel et
leur principal atout l'envie la passion
parce que il a fallu énormément de
travail revenir pendant les vacances
travailler pendant ses jours jours de
congé et puis une remise en question
perpétuelle permanente parce que parce
que voilà c'est jamais correct c'est
jamais bon c'est jamais parfait donc il
a fallu en permanence travailler ils ont
ces qualités là beaucoup de travail et
une motivation mise à rue d'épreuve
j'avoue j'ai failli abandonner à un
moment parce
que c'est vrai qu'on enfin on rêve on
mange MAF on on rêve MAF et cetera donc
voilà mais après faut faut persévérer
franchement je regrettete vraiment pas
que les prof fa s mon pousser et d'avoir
persévérer làdedans quoi parmi les
épreuves la reconnaissance de produits
comme ici avec un plateau de fromage
juste derrière donc vous avez Lect donc
qui provient d'auverg mais aussi une
mise en place de table une argumentation
commerciale une démonstration de crê
flambé comme ici je vais bientôt pouvoir
flamber comme ceci on présente bien
comme ceci met un peu de su ou encore la
préparation d'un
cocktail
donc c'est un cocktail qui est frappé au
checker des épreuves qu'il retrouveront
au baccalauréat dans quelques mois ce
concours permet en tout cas de mettre en
lumière et de valoriser leur filière peu
visible on n pas seulement des porteurs
d'assiette il y a des connaissance à
savoir sur les fromages les vins des
accords avec à faire avec les les plats
anaë rêve de concilier voyage et
travaille nous la retrouverons peut-être
sur des bateaux de croisière Cameron
souhaiterait de son côté travailler dans
un grand
le nouveau ti devrait leur permettre de
réaliser leur
rêv et c'est la fin de ce 78 lactu
retour de votre édition lundi avec
Wilfred Richy dans un instant le 78
weekend présenté par Anthony Resche
excellente soirée sur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
TVfil